movie fans know that you're supposed to
stay in your seat until after the
credits roll just in case you forgot
however here's a rundown on the biggest
post credits moments of the Year
spoilers ahead the third Ant-Man movie
sees Scott Lang once again Dawning his
size shifting suit to venture into the
quantum realm there he encounters the
despotic villain King the Conqueror
you're an interesting
man scotl in the first of two
post-credit scenes Kang's defeat is
shown to be not quite as final as it
seems we see hundreds of variants of
Kang discussing how to avenge their
fallen friend in a chilling moment that
offers a sneak peek at what to expect in
upcoming MCU projects finally we see the
first big screen appearance of Loki
since 2019 as the god of Mischief comes
face to face with another of Kang's
variants during a theatrical lecture of
course we now know that this is a clear
teaser for the second season of Loki
demonstrating just how far-reaching
King's presence will be in the next
phase of the MCU one of the stranger
releases of 2023 cocaine bear took a be
movie premise and bumped it up to a big
budget project the film kicks off with a
batch of cocaine thrown out of a
Smuggler's aircraft where it is picked
up and consumed by a black bear deep in
the Georgia Woods you can probably guess
what happens next let's see what kind of
effect that has on in the first of a
pair of mid-credit scenes it is shown
that stash the sole survivor of the
local Duchamp gang escaped with what
cocaine didn't wind up inside the bear
in the second scene it is revealed that
both Eddie and deid managed to survive
the ordeal with Eddie motivated to
reconcile with his estranged son and
okay neither scene lays a solid
foundation for a sequel given the fact
that nobody actually kills the bear
however and given the film's box office
access to boot it's fair to say we may
yet see cocaine bear too somewhere down
the road Shazam Fury of the God saw the
return of the titular red suited hero
this time duking it out with the
daughters of Atlas on a quest quest for
revenge like many superhero movies the
latest Shazam title treats audiences to
a pair of post-credit scenes after the
film's conclusion both of which tease
future installments the first depicts a
meeting between Shazam and
representatives of the Justice Society
who are looking to recruit him as their
latest addition I just want to be in the
Wonder Woman group so that's you guys
right no why are you so obsessed with
Wonder Woman dude the second post-credit
scene may give you a little Deja Vu if
you stuck around after the first Shazam
this scene yet again teases a scheme
between Dr Savana and the caterpillar
super villain Mr Mind the irony of
essentially using these same post-credit
scene for both films wasn't lost on
director Adam F Sandberg who stated in
an interview with DC that the reprisal
was a result of Fury of the God's
complicated plot Sandberg confirmed mrm
is still working on something but time
will tell whether the nefarious
caterpillar's long-awaited scheme will
ever make it out of the jail housee the
Adam Driver L sci-fi thriller 65 took
audiences back in time to a brief period
when dinosaurs and Aliens roamed the
Earth set 65 million years ago driver's
Captain Mills finds himself on a deep
space journey that goes horribly wrong
leaving him and one other Survivor
stranded on a hostile version of planet
Earth forced to contend against massive
dinosaurs and an impending mass
extinction event the unlikely Duo
eventually manages to escape the doomed
planet in the nick of time so what
exactly could the post-credit scene add
to this story as it turns out not all
that much as the credits roll the
devastating effects of the asteroid are
shown as well as the subsequent
Millennia of evolution that follow this
scene also dispels any fears that Mill's
arrival on Earth might have changed the
course of history the asteroid still
collides with the planet and the events
that follow don't seem to differ from
what we know today the finality of this
scene also means that the chances of a
sequel are pretty unlikely a fact
compounded by the movie's lackluster box
office video game adaptations rarely
farewell in H Hollywood that all changed
in 2023 however with the Super Mario
Brothers movie a film that broke the
mold and delivered on the series decades
long Legacy featuring an All-Star lineup
of Comedy Talent led by Chris Pratt the
movie finds plumber Brothers Mario and
Luigi become embroiled in a war between
Princess Peach's Mushroom Kingdom and
the evil Bowser's Koopas audiences are
treated to two scenes after the movie
the first of which gives us one last
look at Jack Black's memorable song
Peaches as Bowser reprises it from
behind bar next up and back in real
world Brooklyn a familiar spotted egg
begins to
[Music]
hatch with the film making more than
$1.3 billion do worldwide a sequel is
all but confirmed and it stands to
reason that we'll get to see some more
of Yoshi somewhere down the line the
John Wick series needs little
introduction debuting nearly a decade
ago a lone action-packed Revenge
Thriller quickly evolved into something
much bigger with the late latest
installment finding Wick facing off
against the Sinister high table in a
first for the franchise John Wick
chapter 4 features a brief but important
post-credit scene one that follows a
particularly shocking ending though
we're led to believe John Wick is dead
by the end of chapter 4 this doesn't
mean that every loose string has been
tied up Cain is still alive and were're
given a final glimpse of Akira as she
tracks him down hoping to exact revenge
on behalf of her late father since the
film's release director Chad stahelski
has opened up on what exactly the scene
means both for Akira and for the future
of the franchise stating we have John
Wick and his demise and we're like well
let's open the door to the new John
based on the massively popular
role-playing game Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves proved to be the
first onscreen adaptation of the game to
be loved by critics and fans alike the
film follows the Vagabond Edan who sets
off to find a powerful tablet that will
not only reunite him with his long lost
daughter but also potentially resurrect
his dead wife at one point Edan and his
team team arrive at a graveyard where
they use the powers of necromancy to
gain Vital Information from a cohort of
long dead Warriors after the credits
role we revisit the graveyard only to
discover that the gang didn't finish
their end of the ritual leaving one of
the summoned corpses unable to return to
its Eternal Slumber though it was a
brilliant comedic moment that could
easily have been Revisited in a
follow-up film honor among Thieves
underperformed at the box office so it's
possible that the Unlucky corpse will be
waiting for all of eternity for his
final quest
beloved for its quirky characters and
offbeat sense of humor it's not a
stretch to say the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise redefined the superhero
genre back in 2014 and the final
installment makes for a fitting finale
for the series I'm done running like
most Marvel movies we given two post
credit scenes here the First shows
rocket now leader of a new team of
Guardians defending a bunch of Innocence
on an unknown Planet while it is likely
intended to be a positive sendoff for
many fans favorite scruffy hero this
could also serve as a leadin for a
future project featuring this new gang
the second scene is a little simpler
showing Star-Lord now reunited with his
grandfather on Earth tantalizingly this
scene ends with the promise that the
legendary Star-Lord will return whatever
the future may hold for the Guardians
one thing is certain since James gun has
jumped Shi to helm the DC Universe it
will be entirely different from anything
we've seen before the Fast and the
Furious series of films have become some
of Hollywood's most iconic and profit
titles starting off as a simple Heist
story with a heavy focus on racing the
stakes and the action set pieces have
only gotten bigger with every new
release 2023 is fast X the first half of
the Epic finale to the franchise
continues this trajectory at the end of
the movie the fates of all our heroes
are left unknown thanks to the
villainous Dante to make matters more
complicated the post-credit scene
delivers a surprising reveal in which
Dom's on again off again friend Hobbs
gets a call from Dante warning him that
he's next John son's absence was felt in
F9 so fans will be no doubt excited to
get confirmation that he'll return for
the Final Chapter continuing the story
for which 2018s bumblebee laid the
groundwork Transformers rise of the
beasts marked the end of the longest
Hiatus that the liveaction series has
gone through since it debuted back in
2007 the latest entry in the franchise
takes the fight to Earth as the humans
and Autobots unite against the impending
threat of Unicron while the post-credit
scene doesn't quite match the hype of
the film's unexpected crossover ending
it still makes for a pretty important
moment the scene begins with Noah
tinkering away at a car only for it to
Spring to life revealing that Mirage has
been successfully brought back from the
brink of death this seems to suggest
Mirage will take up arms to defend Earth
again in the near future however
producer Lorenzo D bonaventura told
variety that a sequel might even see the
action move to other planets saying we
have spent a lot of time on Earth and
I'm curious as to what else is out there
it seems that just about every superhero
movie is playing with the concept of the
Multiverse these days and this year the
flash joined in on the fun still
mourning the death of his mother and the
wrongful imprisonment of his father
decades later Barry Allen decides to try
and write the wrongs of his past with
some unpredictable consequences you want
to get
nuts let's get nuts given that much of
the flash amounts to 2 and a half hours
of multiversal Madness the soulle
post-credit scene is surprising ly
lowkey as the credits roll we see the
Flash and Aquaman leaving a bar together
after trying to wrap his heads around
the concept of the Multiverse Aquaman
opts to call it a night lying in a
drunken stuper on the street and that's
that for the
DCU in cidus the red door is the fifth
entry in the legendary horror franchise
the movie picks up years after the
traumatic possession that rocked the
Lambert family to its core and caused a
divorce between parents Josh and Renee
by the film's conclusion both Jos and
his son Dalton have managed to overcome
their many differences and join forces
against the red-faced demon persevering
through their combined traumas and
banishing the evil from their lives for
good or so they think of course if
there's one thing horror films are known
for it's their numerous sequels and the
post-credit scene in The Red Door
certainly suggests a future for the
series in a final brief scene a lone
light above the door that keeps the
demon at Bay begins to falter and
flicker suggesting that the seal Dalton
applied may not hold forever
sound of Freedom Chronicles the
struggles between law enforcement and
child traffickers across the Americas
and given that sound of freedom is a far
cry from the rest of this year's
releases it stands to reason that its
post-credit sequence would also be quite
unlike any of the others the epilog
shows the real life Tim Ballard the film
is based on featuring footage from his
Congressional hearings on child
trafficking to hammer home the movie's
message even further star Jim cavel then
returns to the screen encouraging
audiences to share this film with others
in the hope that they can help end child
trafficking for good serving as the
latest reboot of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles franchise mutant Mayhem
seems to have finally struck some of the
gold that made the series so popular to
begin with the latest spin on the
franchise sees the heroes in a half
shell taking on Superfly who's gunning
for World Domination in a noteworthy
post-credit sequence all four of the
turtles are shown enrolled in the local
high school bringing a close to their
separation from the human world and
demonstrating their ability to over come
Splinter's misguided lessons about the
dangers of humanity meanwhile it's
revealed that the dastardly Cynthia has
Enlisted the help of the Turtles classic
Nemesis Shredder in a new bid to capture
and control them the sof franchise
followed up the experimental spiral from
the book of saw with another unique take
on the horror premise in the jigsaw
centered saw X in this sequel set
between the first two movies John Kramer
gets duped by scammers who stole his
money for a fake cancer treatment in
Mexico the ending reveals a series of
twists but Jon eventually ends up on top
While most of the rest of the cast die
he then returns in the movie's
post-credit scene to the man who set him
up in the first place patient viewers
got to see a mid-credit scene in which
Jon returns to the states and tracks
down Henry Kesler the man who first told
him about the fake treatment in the
sequence we're back in the bathroom from
the original saw where John has Henry
tied up with a gruesome new trap
attached to his stomach in addition to
being a nice homage to the film that
started everything off this scene
implies that Henry was in on the grift
from the start a fact left ambiguous
until the very end of the movie
sometimes we get sucked into things
that are against our nature after the
credits roll on Scream 6 we get one
short medicine that's a joke very much
in line with the tone of the series The
Character Mindy looks into the camera
and tells us not every movie needs a
post-credit scene with that Stinger the
film cuts to Black for the last time
it's a simple meta joke but it didn't go
over well with the fans why well movie
goers are impatient and if they have to
sit through an entire end credits crawl
just to get made fun of well that might
turn some people off understandably the
lack of meaningful content in this scene
makes a lot of fans say that waiting
through to the end wasn't worth the
punchline with respect we disagree the
joke this time is on you it's getting
hard to track which horror movies fall
under the umbrella of The Conjuring
universe but if you went into the nun
two without realizing it was part of
this franchise you would have been
thoroughly reminded by its post-credit
sequence which ties this spin-off
directly back to the main Conjuring
movies as far as the story of the Nunu
is concerned everything is wrapped up by
the time this credit scene rolls it is
1956 and at a Convent in Italy Sister
Irene and sister Deborah fight off
possessions and a demon nun which they
managed to successfully banish back to
Hell after the credits though time has
clearly moved forward we hear a phone
answered as Ed and Lorraine Warren and
enter the room from outside the woman
tells Ed its father Gordon a priest who
frequently works with the Warren on
their cases on the line before the scene
ends Ed picks up the phone and teases
their next adventure by saying yes
Father how can we help we know the next
movie in The Conjuring universe is going
to feature the Warren what we don't know
yet is just when The Conjuring last
rights will go into production
scheduling has been delayed by the
Hollywood strikes no you weren't
Bamboozled if you saw barbie when it
originally came to theaters and missed
this post credit sequence when Greta
gerwig's much anticipated Blockbuster
first hit the theaters the same day as
Oppenheimer there was no post credits
anything a montage of deleted scenes
outtakes and bloopers was added at the
end for the IMAX re-release of the film
in September 2023 I can practically feel
my heels lifting already Yes this
extended blooper reel is full of little
Goofs and gags that didn't make it into
the Final Cut of the movie new scenes
include an exchange between Ryan
Gosling's Ken and weird Barbie Gosling
singing a spoof of Cindy loppers Girls
Just Want to Have Fun and mijch the
pregnant doll going into labor we didn't
think it possible but there are also
many more references to Mattel toys like
Barney Hot Wheels and Thomas the Tank
Engine there's also just a bunch of
silly lines and improvisations that
finally get to see the light of day you
don't need a breakdown of the latest
Pixar movies lore to understand the
meaning behind its post-credit scene
Elemental follows a group of
anthropomorphized elements of nature in
a story about different groups coming
together bringing the Polar Opposites of
fire and water together serves as the
central metaphor as Ember and Wade begin
to fall for each other throughout the
adventure director Peter sa based The
Narrative and Elemental of his
experience growing up as a child of
immigrants in New York City the movie is
dedicated to both of his parents which
you might have only realized if you
stuck around for the credits we are not
sure if it's a full scene but there is a
brief in memorium at the end of
Elemental that serves as a heartwarming
cherry on top of the rest of the film we
love this because it's such a rare
example of using the post-credit scene
in a personal and meaningful way it
makes audiences feel good for sticking
around in the first five nights at
Freddy's video game players inhabit a
security guard working inside the
rundown Freddy Fazbear's Pizza similar
to places like Chuck-E-Cheese and must
survive the titles five nights without
getting killed by the aformentioned
animatronics the 2023 feature film
adaptation follows much of the same
beats as the original game while of
course expanding on the character's
backstory in the film Mike Schmidt the
security guard protagonist is entrusted
with taking care of his disabled sister
Abby Mike accepts the Shady job offer at
Freddy fazbears to keep custody of her
eventually the ghost children possessing
the animatronics want to turn Abby into
one of them they want to make her like
them Freddy even comes to Mike and aby's
home to kidnap her afterward Abby and
Freddy take a taxi back to Fazbear's
Pizza in a comedic scene as the driver
is seemingly unperturbed by Freddy's
appearance in a mid-credit scene the
taxi driver returns only to be menaced
by balloon boy an animatronic character
who appears in the game 5 Nights at
Freddy's 2 and who is seen sporadically
throughout the film it's a funny if
inconsequential sequence however there's
also an eerie after credits moment where
a creepy electronic voice appears to say
find me or come find
[Music]
me